yes movies Heather Morris opening up for
the first time about Naya Rivera
tragic death I hope we have Heather
posted an emotional tribute to Instagram
sharing photos of their kids spending
time together
nya's son Josie and a Heather sons
Elijah and Owen she wrote I have
countless pictures of our babies playing
because we shared that kind of pride and
joy so I'm showing the world a photo of
our little goofballs for you because I
know that meant more than anything and
they remind me of you and died and one
of the things that fans are so excited
about is that your on-screen wife is now
expecting a baby of her own just like
you had a baby have you been able to
give Maya any advice we've been talking
about it you know over and over like
it's just I'm excited cuz now my baby
has a friend and we're just stoked about
it before nighas body was recovered in
Lake Piru on Monday Heather was one of
the many people holding on to hope she
had posted this message to her Instagram
story we need all the prayers we can get
to bring our nya back home to us hey I'm
really sorry that I can't go an hour
without seeing you cos I'm just missing
you too much Heather and I up a trade to
fan favorite characters on Glee Brittany
and Santana who ended up getting married
during the hit shows a final season
that's not us okay because you love me
and I love you and no silly
superstitions are gonna change that
you
[Music]